xavier breton député l air de l'ain
[Musique]
bonjour xavier breton
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct dans la matinale de france
alors on l'a vu un nouveau conseil de
défense cette semaine pour décider ou
pas d'un nouveau confinement avec une
possible prise de parole des manuels
macron dans les prochains jours on va
écouter si vous le voulez bien le
ministre de la santé
justement sur ce possible confinement et
on en parle après tout les laboratoires
sont mobilisés pour nous permettre
d'avoir des indicateurs de suivi de
croissance du variant parce que je n'en
va pas se mentir là le développement de
la propagation du variant d'origine
anglaise sur le territoire français
peut-être un élément déterminant dans
les stratégies de lutte contre
l'épidémie que nous pourrions déployés
dans les prochains jours et des
prochaines semaines
et si la part de variants c'est le voc
2020 devait augmenter de façon sensible
et que nous devions suivre une
trajectoire allant gleizes le
confinement deviendrait probablement une
nécessité absolue
alors on est a priori en train de suivre
cette fameuse trajectoire à l anglaise
avec l'arrivée des nouveaux variants sur
le territoire ses prises de décisions au
conseil de défense ont jugé assez opaque
par bon nombre de parlementaires quelle
est votre position
oui je crois qu'effectivement le
gouvernement les décisions ne sont pas
faciles à prendre dans tous les pays la
planète qui sont confrontés à cette
pandémie pour autant maintenant ça va
faire un an que nous sommes dans une
situation exceptionnelle et on a
l'impression qu'elles sont ne sont pas
tirées de confinement des cons filmant
au confinement etc
on l'a bien vu encore la semaine
dernière avec le texte qui vise à à
prolonger l'urgence sanitaire et donc
donne encore une fois qu'il ya un état
d'urgence dans une situation de crise de
manière ponctuelle de toute façon à ce
que l'exécutif est au pouvoir pour
adapter un petit peu notre
réglementation la situation c'est normal
mais que cet état d'urgence sanitaire
l'occurrence se prolonge
là je pense que ça ça pose un problème a
fortiori quand le parlement est écarté
des décisions et que c'est en fait un
conseil scientifique
on ne connaît pas la légitimité
démocratique qui prend le coût de ces
décisions dont ça pose un vrai problème
c'est vrai voix en plus l'adhésion des
français n'est plus là 40% seulement
favorable à un nouveau continent alors
qu'ils étaient bien plus on s'en
souvient en mars dernier est-ce qu'il
faut selon vous ce confinement ou pas je
pense qu'effectivement on voit que les
éléments amènent à prendre cette
décision
mais s'il ya des réticences je pense que
ça s'explique aussi par deux éléments le
premier c'est que on sait que si on
avait eu ce premier confinement très dur
vous printemps dernier c'est parce que
d'en haut niveau de nos capacités
hospitalières voulait d'étranglement qui
faisait qu effectivement nos services de
réanimation n'était pas en état
d'accueillir toutes les personnes qui en
avaient besoin
et donc on a eu ce mot se profile mans
où se retrouvent un an après et on se
retrouve toujours avec ces mêmes goulets
d'étranglement qui empêche effectivement
hélas d'accueillir suffisamment de
personnes donc on voit bien que sur ce
plan là rien n'a été vraiment le
deuxième deuxième explication je pense
de la réticence des français c'est
l'attitude du gouvernement je pense que
les français comprennent que c'est pas
fatigué que c'est une ville qui n'est
pas facile à lire et ça il le président
a fait part courte ce qui ne supporte
pas c'est un peu le l'autosuffisance
cette incapacité d'autocritique du
gouvernement je crois que le code dans
la république promet ni ses ministres
mieux de faire preuve de plus un peu de
modestie d'expliquer les choses aux
français qui sont tout à fait comprendre
capable de comprendre les difficultés
mais d'entendre ces essais nous ils en
sortent pour le mieux et c'est alors on
prend les bonnes décisions il n'y a pas
besoin de se justifier
on voit bien les chiffres ne sont pas
bons ni au niveau sanitaire ni au niveau
économique donc un peu de modestie c'est
loupé alors on va parler des chiffres de
la vaccination à présent 70 millions de
français vaccinés d'ici fin août c'est
l'objectif au combien ambitieux annoncé
par le ministre de la santé
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya plus de
deux vaccins en stock est ce que vous
parlementaire vous allez des chiffres
précis concernant les commandes et
surtout des dates précises de mise à
disposition pour les français dont là
dessus effectivement on attend du
gouvernement se rend compte qu'il y
avait déjà eu
pénurie au niveau des masques s'était
ensuite au niveau du test chaque fois
que le gouvernement nous dit on va être
prêts là on arrive au les vaccins on
l'est toujours pas donc là aussi
s'interroge je crois que la campagne de
vaccination au niveau collectif elle
aura des effets pour pas caché qu'il
peut y avoir au niveau individuel
personnel des effets secondaires qui ne
sont pas souhaitables
on est en train d'avancer dans cette
avec ce système de vaccins mais là aussi
la mode de communication on n'incite pas
la cour à la confiance mais précis
parlementaire justement sur cette
campagne de vaccination non alors il va
y avoir il y à un haut niveau de la
commission des affaires sociales qui
suit particulièrement je suis moi
personnellement la commission des lois
et on est actuellement sur des textes
séparatistes menés sur la commission des
affaires sociales elle va une réunion
consacrée effectivement pour avoir des
chiffres précis et puis également des
perspectives parce qu'il ya bien sûr la
le premier vaccin vient ensuite le
deuxième dose qui est à prévoir et là où
il ya aussi beaucoup d'interrogations
donc tout ça le crs avec beaucoup de
points d'incertitude on va parler du
bureau de la sécurité qu'il s'ouvre
aujourd'hui à 15 heures grande
concertation avec les syndicats de
police pour améliorer les conditions
d'exercice écouter ce qu'on a dit eric
ciotti le député des alpes-maritimes le
diagnostic tout le monde le connaît le
malaise de la police sa paupérisation
il en est de même pour la justice
d'ailleurs je redoute donc que ce temps
supposé des changes soit la libye de
l'inaction est ce que ces pourvois un
coup de communication
oui on revient que le gouvernement qui
n'a pas fait les réformes qui devait
être fait ou des buteuses de son mandat
tant qu'il n'y avait pas de crise eh
bien depuis que ces crises existe alors
soit elles viennent de l'extérieur c'est
quand même sur ces différentes crises
qu'il a lui-même provoqué je pense à la
crise des gilets jaunes et bien les
toutes les réformes qui n'ont pas été
faites sont d'affaires et comme
la situation devient intenable c'est le
cas bien sûr dans les personnels de
santé mais ces cas également pour nos
forces de l'ordre eh bien on a vente des
grenelles de ceux-ci et bovo de cela
mais pendant ce temps les semaines et
les mois passent on arrive à l'échéance
présidentielle très rapidement et rien
n'aurait été fait dans son froc le
diagnostic tout le monde le partage
maintenant ce qui compte c'est une
volonté politique est manifestement le
gouvernement et la majorité n'ont pas de
majorité c'est une volonté politique
fait partie de la commission sur la loi
dite séparatisme qui ne porte pas le nom
de séparatisme vendredi le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est un peu moqué de vous
et de votre famille politique à
l'assemblée regardez il ya 50 nuance de
heller on l'a bien compris entre un
amendement de monsieur ciotti qui veut
tout interdire
je caricature à peine les madame
genevard qui pensent l'un vers ce entre
xavier breton très libertarien qui dit
qu'il ne faut pas interdire et monsieur
diar qui nous dit que finalement c'est
très intéressant
je serais très curieux de connaître le
vote final de ce texte
cela fait trois jours madame blain que
vous nous trouvez tous les arguments
pour ne pas voter le texte
vous ne pouvez pas demander aux
gouvernements d'être dur et quand il
l'est de ne pas lui donner les armes de
l'être c'est complètement irresponsable
ou totalement politiciens du vat on le
connaît puisque l'examen du projet en
commission a été validée ce week-end
prochaine étape 1er février à
l'assemblée ça s'annonce comment tout
d'abord pour dire j'ai un darmanin se
trompe quand il parle de 50 ans de
guerre pour deux raisons d'abord s'il y
avait plusieurs millions à 50 mais 49
passes qui lui n'en fait plus partie je
rappelle quand même
il est qu'il en était à l'origine et
puis deuxièmement sur le vote on a eu un
vote unanime contre ce texte en
commission
donc voilà c'est aussi le préciser et
puis c'est aussi normal que sur tel ou
tel article y ait des débats qui existe
au sein d'un groupe parlementaire quand
on est sur la question par exemple de
l'enseignement la manière de tergnier de
la liberté dans celle du monde peut y
avoir des sensibilités différentes par
rapport à la vie associative là aussi
donc simplement ce qu elle pourquoi on
vote contre ce texte c'est qu'à la fois
il n'est pas efficace dans l'objet du
texte qui est la lutte contre le
séparatisme on voit bien que tous les
amendements que nous avons déposés pour
renforcer cette rude
contre le communautarisme le séparatisme
ont été refusées et puis d'un autre côté
il ya des mesures de portée générale qui
ne sombre pas décidé qui l'avons embêter
tous nos concitoyens de vis à vis qui
souhaitent élever leurs enfants à
domicile ou dans des danses et des
talismans et leur compte pas les
associations qui vont être obligés de
signer un contrat d'engagement
républicains comme si l hérault se
méfier des débats tout ça ça montre que
c'est une conception de notre république
qui est imposée est vraiment d'autant
bas où on dit aux français voilà il faut
que vous signez là et puis quand il n'y
a pas d'autres débats possible pour vous
l'esprit démocratique esprit républicain
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
partagée par des initiatives qui
viennent des balkans ou et non pas une
tutelle de l'état qui viendrait dire
voilà il faut être de bons pieds
républicain c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche
merci beaucoup vous aviez breton d'avoir
est vendu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france